Hi there, I'm showing you in this video a real-time version of the visualization
model I'm working on this last month and this is a model that I'm utilizing quite
a lot to work with birdsongs and I actually began developing it as a
solution for birdsong visualization and analysis and this is the first 100%
real-time version that I created. I'm using the sloppy webcam that I have here
and the microphone it has as an audio source and in this version the model is
not designed to represent anything specific like I don't know specific
features in the spectrogram frequencies whatever it's kind of a general-purpose
one but it can actually do some cool stuff and some quite interesting thing
so basically what the model does is to interpret and translate the audio as
point and to distribute the points into 3d space like to create a special
images of the sound and these points end up creating this kind of
intricate layered networks and every point comes with with a subset of
information embedded on it so every point has a color and the color
indicates the most active frequency band at the moment of emission so it's not a
precise frequency measurement it tells you more or less where the most energy
is in the signal at every moment so it's like a frequency zone or tells you
where the sound is going. Another value is the amplitude value on top of every
point there is an emission time expressed in seconds on the bottom there
is a relative lifetime also expressed in seconds it's an animated value and in
this last version there is a new data tool on the left which is the spectral
centroid expressed in kilohertz and the spectral centroid is like the center of
mass of the spectrogram it's like an average of everything that's going on in
the spectrogram at a certain moment of time so basically every point now has
also the mean frequency of everything that is going on in the spectrogram and
higher values suggest a brighter signal while darker values indicates a lower
values indicate a darker one and yeah so you can tell how my usual voice range
my normal voice range stays at about 200 Hertz but I can try to
change the pitch with my voice so with some falsetto like and you can tell how
this reflects into the model with changes in colors and shape distribution
the shape of the points also so basically my voice is constantly shaping
and reshaping the model over time in in space and another feature that I devised
with this version is the possibility to save snapshots of the structure and this
is an extremely interesting thing so basically at any moment I am able to
freeze the real-time flow and have a create a still 3d model of it with all
the data embedded of it so I can try to have a snapshot now and see how it looks
like so yeah basically this is a 3d model of my voice we can call it that
you can tell how the different values are for every point the distribution the
different colors etc I can also navigate it a bit with this amazing zoom slider
that I build for the occasion and you can also tell how the normal range of my
voice has also higher frequency particles embedded on it which
basically are the SSD sounds that I do when I talk and it's interesting to see
how they are somehow sampled and inserted into the 3d model organically
so I can switch back to the real-time generation at any moment and basically
this is all data these are numbers data sets which can be saved and elaborated
in many different ways they can be put into libraries they can be analytically
compared they can be putting relationship one with the other and they
can also be represented in different ways into graph and such so for instance
in this version I built a couple of secondary graphs which are already into
the touch designer network so I can have another snapshot now and see how they
look like so yeah this is another 3d model of my voice and I built a graph
that puts in relationship amplitude and frequency over time so here we have the
amplitude values on the y-axis and the time window in which the snapshot has
been taken on the x-axis which is 10 seconds but it can be virtually any time
and the colored points are the frequency information for every point so
basically what you see here you see here this is the same thing it's just data
that is represented differently so basically you have a 3d model here with
additional XY and Z information for every point and you have the same data
here reported into a linear b-dimensional graph and you see how it
looks like and another graph that I built puts in relationship the
spectral centric values with the amplitude values and it's cool to see
how the brightness of the signal can more or less relate with its amplitude
so these are two possibilities of lots of possibilities that can be can be done
with this model which basically is not just a simple visualizer is more like it
can be a real-time audio analysis tool that can be used for a number of
different purposes and the users are quite they can be very much and yeah I'm
going to implement many other functions in the in the future work that I'm doing
on this I have already many ideas of what to do and yeah now I can try
something crazier with my voice like I can try to save a snapshot of this crap
and see how it looks like okay you can see the normal range of my voice you can
see my faceto range quite clearly and my whistle too that is embedded as a
structure like per se into the overall model and I can see how it looks like in
the graphs you can tell how my falsetto amplitude goes basically off scale in
the graph but you can also clearly detect all the episodes in that I did
mean my voice in the time dimension which is pretty cool and also I can see
how the spectral centroid and amplitude relates this model so yeah this is where
my work is the direction where my work is going at the moment and another very
cool thing that I'm trying to do with this model is to feed it any audio source
I can find because it can process every audio so basically whatever can produce
a sound can be fed into it so I can try maybe some drawing or an almonica or the ringtones of my cell phone
so this is basically how I'm wasting my time right now
yeah this is like the state of the art of my work and and this is what I'm
doing and as a further development on this model I'm going to introduce MIDI
so I'm going to implement MIDI on it and I'm very curious to see where it can go
because another project I'm very much involved now is the visual MIDI guitar
and I'm seriously interested what on seeing what can be achieved with these
different technologies put together and yeah I think also that when I be done
with all the development work I try to talk a bit more in depth about how these
models are actually built because the workflow is not really easy there are
many things many techniques going together at once and the touch designer
networks are rather colossal so it would require quite an effort to actually
explain everything and also recording quality now is not really great because
I'm going completely in real time and even if I have a rather powerful GPU is
barely holding everything together so I'm doing what I can anyway yeah I guess
that's it for now and if you want more of that you can like and subscribe as
they say since more is to come I'm mostly active on Instagram but every
now and then I come back to YouTube to post some development of my work I try
to be more regular here and post more stuff and maybe also some some more
creative thing and we'll see where it goes thanks a lot for watching and see
you soon bye